ultimate Val McDermid
if you were to let's say this this
is yourn yeah and this is Maria yes if
you were to use them cause them as
characters in some some crime fiction
mm-hmm how would you call them would I
be the crook well it would be this you
would be someone with a dark secret in
your past you've had such an interesting
and varied past uh-huh you would
obviously have some dark secret that you
didn't want people to know mmm mmm but I
think you would be a red herring not a
killer oh good what about my dealer I
think you're gonna be even be the
glamorous femme fatale oh thats quiet my
view wrestlers on your songs yeah I'd
love that I am actually after the after
the like CSI all over everything that
happened I wondered if I could commit
the perfect murder and I've been
wondering about that something I'm
pretty excited about hearing you well
the perfect mother is the one that
people don't realize is a murder oh so
one that looks like an accident or
something unfortunate that happens or a
suicide that's the perfect murder and
there's no suspicion of murder how do
you cast mr. skavlan here haha your
leader horribly the victim haha I don't
know how many people have you upset in
your career Oh quite a few quite yeah so
you would be an interesting victim then
because it would be lots of suspects
yeah and I look so innocent yes but you
have very dangerous I'd Rose first yeah
I I thought that's a first for me tell
me actually you you were you once called
you you went by the name of the killer
right yeah when I was a journalist with
you before I actually killed anybody yes
what what what kind of journalists were
you um I was just I was a general
reporter um I was pretty low down the
totem pole initially had just got sent
on any story that came in and gradually
I worked myself up till I was the
northern bureau chief of a national
Sunday newspaper and then I could sit in
the office and just show to everybody
else and that's why they called you the
killer or is it I was called the killer
before that um I think because I was
at a reputation for going out and
nailing stories I went out the office to
get a story I came back with the story
and there were not many women back then
in this kind of journalist oh well no
and when I when I joined the Scottish
newspaper that I went for for a few
years the Daily Record there were only
three women on the staff and we were
never allowed to be on the same shift
together so there was only ever one
woman in the newsroom at a time while
the Bible's i don't know i think they
thought maybe if we if we work together
we would conspire against them but when
i first went to the newspaper it was
only just it only been six months since
women were actually allowed to wear
trousers in the office and and and not
very long they were only allowed to go
out on night shift for a few months
before i arrived because it was
apparently too dangerous in glasgow at
night for women to be out reporting so
when you went out on the story were
there any advantage being able them well
they were often advantages i think in
situations where you're trying to
persuade people to talk to you i think
people find women less threatening than
men and more willing to confide in you
and there is one one special trick that
women can use that men can't get away
with if you're trying to speak to
somebody and they won't give you an
interview and they won't let you in the
house the thing you could always do as a
woman as say please can I use your
bathroom see if the guys say that they
just go like go behind the hedge but if
a woman says please can I come in and
use your bathroom almost always they let
you come in and once you get in the
house you've got something even if it's
all right
yes you have to be devious you know the
famous people or quite often have things
named after them i mean real famous bhm
like like an institute or a library and
and you you also have something named
after you but it's a morgue yeah that's
right mortuary yeah what is that about
how did that happen well I I I know a
lot of forensic scientists have been
very helpful to me over the years and
one of them as a friend's account to
follow just called professor su black at
the university of dundee and sue wanted
to build a new mortuary with a new
technique of embalming so i rounded up a
bunch of other crime writers will also
use forensics in their books and we set
up a competition called a million for a
morgue and we asked our fans to vote for
us and eventually we raised the money
and so the person who got the most votes
got the mortuary named after them and i
was the lucky one so so i get to go in
there as much as you want as it's your
name oh I I could go there and win there
as much yeah okay once i would imagine
that the thing that you'd love to do
that in with no no i don't i don't
really like dead bodies and blood done
see that's such a why do you and you but
you do write about them right you're
fascinated about it are you okay with
touching and no cuz it's the only know i
really don't like blood are you
squeamish um when I'm writing I'm in
control nothing happens without me
saying so and it's not real I know I'm
just making this stuff up obviously when
I read other people's work it feels real
yeah and I hope that when my reloaded my
work it feels real but the real thing I
just know I don't want to do that your
dumb buckets nope I really don't like it
but do you think you will end up in that
not sure even yes some you know I'm
gonna give them my body even I die it
will be a big day there I mean without
ha I don't know bill does that actually
have a party they get all my body except
I have artificial knees yeah I have
attained IAM neighs yeah so I said I
said to Professor black I said you can
have all my body but when my son gets my
knees so he can make some nice jewelry
out of the titanium
there definitely is that well you get
paid for the scrap metal vote yeah yeah